台积电和阳明交通大学共同发表的论文
就是在二流化木二维材料
和氧化哈借电材料之间
成长一层
累经衍生的氧化铝界面层
这一层累经衍生的氧化铝界面层
主要的作用就是改善二维材料
二流化木的界面特性
这样就可以减少散射效应
增加宅子在二流化木
二维材料里面的迁移率
也就是增加电子电动
移动的速度
而且在论文里面台积电已经把这样的技术做成元件
虽然电子通道100奈米有点大
但是呢
未来各位曲博科技教师的观众朋友大家好
我是曲博
最近台积电次世代技术再突破
和阳明交通大学共同发表论文在自然电子期刊
使用累金界面工程来实现高跨岛的二流化木
顶部杂集电晶体
大家都知道1奈米以下的先进制程
将会使用二流化木这种二维材料
来作为宅子移动的通道
但是二流化木和上面的氧化哈
这种高界电常数的绝缘体
会产生许多效应
造成宅子移动的速度变慢
那么这一次台积电
和阳明交通大学的科学家
是如何使用累经界面工程
来解决这个问题呢
我们今天就来和大家谈谈这个题目
所以我们今天的题目是
台积电次世代技术再突破
累晶界面工程实现高跨导二流化木顶部杂集电晶体
首先我们和大家介绍高跨导对长效电晶体的重要性
以及累晶界面工程如何解决二维长效电晶体的问题
再来我们介绍累晶衍生的氧化铝和氧化哈氧化铝堆叠结构的界电特性
以及基于化学气象层机CVD成长单层二流化木的双杂集长效电晶体
再来我们介绍短通道顶部杂集长效电晶体
和高界电长速杂集堆叠结构的特性比较
最后我们和大家谈谈
累晶衍生氧化铝界面层
主要的作用是改善二维材料的界面
我们今天的这条来源是阳明交通大学
以及台积电的科学家
发表在自然电子期刊
题目是利用累晶界面工程
实现高跨岛二流化木顶部杂集电晶体
首先高跨岛是长效电晶体
的关键性能指标之一
会直接影响电压增益
切换速度以及频宽
在二维场效电晶体中
要实现高跨导
需要同时具备
低的等效氧化层厚度
并且缩短通道长度
以及维持载子迁移率
也就是电子电动
移动的速度等等条件
然而这三项因素
很难同时最佳化
也就是等效氧化层的厚度
缩短通道长度
提高载子迁移率
这三个条件很难同时满足
所谓的跨导
Chance Conductance
又称为转导
是输出端电流的变化量
和输入端电压的变化量的比值
所以跨导GM会等于
输出端的电流变化量
除以输入端的电压变化量
符号使用GM
单位是西门子
用来衡量主动元件
例如厂效电晶体
将电压讯号转换为电流讯号的能力
也就是输入电压造成输出电流的改变
它物理的意义是输入电压没改变一伏特
能够让输出端产生多少安培的电流变化
换句话说
较高的跨导代表元件具有更强的控制能力
能够根据输入电压的变化
有效的调节输出电流
而这一次台积电和阳明交通大学的科学家
透过整合高界电常数HiK的界电材料
可以将等效氧化层厚度降低到1奈米以下
但是减少了等效氧化层厚度
通常会造成界电层相关的散射效应
也就是电子电动受到绝缘层的影响产生散射
这样会降低窄子迁移率
也就是降低电子电动的移动速度
并且限制跨岛的提升
而这个研究呢
科学家证明可以采用累晶界面工程的方法
来制作单层的二流化木
顶部杂奇长焦电晶体
大约在1奈米的等效氧化成厚度下
它的跨岛可以达到每微米长度0.45毫西门子
科学家在超高真空的环境
直接在二流化木的表面成长累晶的铝薄膜
也就是单晶的铝薄膜
原子排列的很整齐
随后在原来的位置上进行低压氧化
形成由铝的累晶衍生出来的氧化铝界面层
这个界面层可以支援氧化哈的均匀整合
并且抑制界电层造成的散射效应
这样就不会造成明显的宅子迁移率降低的情形
从而实现强大的杂集控制能力
换句话说科学家在二流化木和氧化哈之间成长氧化铝界面层
这样就可以抑制界电层
也就是绝缘层的散射效应
这样就可以解决二维电晶体
因为散射效应导致的宅子迁移率降低的问题
接下来我们和大家谈谈高跨导对长效电晶体的重要性
具有高跨导的长效电晶体
是现在所有电子系统里面基本构成的元件
在类比和射频电路中
高跨导可以实现比较大的电压增益
也就是用比较小的电压就可以控制元件
以及频宽操作
在数位逻辑电路
也就是处理器
高跨岛有助于实现高速切换和低功耗因为我们可以用更低的电压控制开关特别是二维材料例如过度金属二流属化物这个是1奈米以下的先进制程
所要使用的材料
由于具有原子尺度的厚度
高载子迁移率
以及良好的静电控制能力
还有和后段制程整合的相容性
也就是和多层金属导线容易整合
被视为次世代电晶体的潜在材料
但是要在二维场效电晶体中实现高跨导
就必须最佳化三项彼此互相依存的因素
而这三项因素之间的关系
可以用下面这个公式来表示
也就是跨导会近视于宅子迁移率
乘以单位面积的杂极氧化成电容
除以通道的长度
再乘以极极到原极的电压
在这个公式里面
μ是宅子迁移率
cox是单位面积的杂极氧化成电容
而这个电容会跟等效氧化成厚度EOT
或者电容等效厚度CET成反比
换句话说等效氧化成厚度越薄
代表单位面积的杂极氧化成电容越大
则电导越高
LG是通道的长度
DDS是极极原极的电压
因此要增加跨导有三个方法
第一个是提高载子迁移率
也就是μ越大跨导越大
降低等效氧化成厚度
EOT
也就是等效氧化成厚度越薄
单位面积的杂集氧化成电容越大
因为它们是呈反比
所以COX越大跨导越大
或者缩短通道长度
LG越小跨导越大
接下来我们介绍累晶界面工程
如何解决二维敞效电晶体的问题
对于二维敞效电晶体而言
同时最佳化前面三项参数
是一个非常大的挑战
尤其是随着界电层的萎缩
也就是绝缘层变薄
界面散射和远端散射效应
往往会导致宅子的迁移率降低
也就是电子电动移动的速度降低
而这个研究就是提出一种
杂吉界电层整合的策略
可以在实现降低等效氧化成厚度的同时
维持足够高的宅子迁移率
而它的做法就是在超高真空的环境中
直接在二流化木的表面
成长大约0.3奈米的超薄累金铝的薄膜
也就是单金的铝薄膜
随后在原来的位置进行低压的氧化
形成次奈米高品质的氧化铝薄膜
作为界面层
这里的氧化铝层同时扮演两种角色
一方面可以作为后续利用原子层层及LD
成长高界电常数的氧化哈的层合层
也就是让氧化哈能够在氧化驴表面成合
另一方面可以作为界面缓冲层来降低界电层
氧化哈所引起的散射
例如我们刚刚提过的远端生子散射
以及界面相关散射
这些散射会让电子电动移动的速度变慢
透过累经界面工程
这样的方法可以实现大概在1奈米的低等效氧化层厚度
达到每伏特每秒大约27平方公分的高本真宅子迁移率
而且呢制作了通道长度大约100奈米的单层二流化木长效电晶体
它的跨导可以达到每微米0.45毫西门子
接下来我们来看这种累晶衍生氧化铝和氧化哈氧化铝堆叠结构的界电特性
在二氧化木上面成长0.3奈米厚度的累晶铝薄膜
再将铝薄膜氧化衍生形成次奈米级
而且没有孔洞的氧化铝作为成合层
再利用这个成合层
透过原子层层基ALD制成成长高界电常数的界电材料
也就是大约3奈米的氧化哈
科学家利用三种不同的结构来进行这个实验
第一种是在细晶元基板上
制作二流化木二维材料
并且在表面上直接成长氧化哈
第二种是在细晶圆基板上
制作二流化木二维材料
并且在上面成长氧化铝成合成
再成长氧化哈
第三种是在细晶圆基板
制作二流化木二维材料
在上面成长累经衍生氧化铝成合成
再成长氧化哈
下面这三张是原子力显微镜照片
显示出氧化哈表面的平整度
从这三张照片可以看出
直接在二流化木表面成长氧化哈
会形成一个一个岛屿状的结构
如果在中间使用氧化铝层合成
则可以让氧化哈表面变得更均匀平整
如果在中间使用
累经衍生的氧化铝层合成
则表面的氧化哈平整度最高
如果没有使用层合成
直接成长氧化哈
则无法完全覆盖二流化木的表面
也就是左边这张照片
这个现象主要是因为二流化木的表面
不存在悬挂件
Dangolin棒
就会导致氧化哈
优先形成导状的结构
所以就变成不连续的表面
所谓的悬挂件
是指固定在金格中的原子
它的电子没有形成完整间接的状态
通常会出现在金体的表面
金格缺陷的地方或者界面的地方
这个时候原子因为缺少临近的原子
没有办法形成完整的供价件
当我们使用原子层层积的制层
在累经衍生氧化铝层合层的上面层长氧化哈就可以形成完整而且均匀的覆盖层也就是右边这张照片并且具有非常低的表面粗糙度
它的均方跟粗糙度
RQ大约0.3nm
代表这个时候表面非常的平整
适合用来制作电子元件
接下来科学家
利用导电式原子力显微镜
CAFM进行量测
检视界电层堆叠结构的漏电流
在量测的时候
是先将单层的二流化木
转移到P形的细晶圆上
接着在二流化木上面
制作借电层氧化铝
还有氧化哈的堆叠结构
最后再用探针尖端
像这个基板局部量测漏电流
从这个量测结果可以看出
如果在二流化木二维材料的表面
直接成长氧化哈
则会形成岛屿的结构
这个时候的漏电流
高达750甚至1500pico安培
如果在二流化木二维材料的表面
先成长氧化铝层合成
再成长氧化哈
则漏电流大约也有800pico安培
但是如果在二流化木二维材料的表面
先成长累经衍生氧化铝层合成
再成长氧化哈
则可以大幅的降低漏电流到接近零
上面这个图是在1.5伏特的偏压下
取得的电流分布图
如果没有使用橙核层的氧化哈
它的电流分布会有较高的漏电流
这是因为氧化哈没有完整覆盖二氧化流的表面所造成的
也就是左边这个图
而采用低温原子层层基成长出氧化铝作为橙核层的样品
它的漏电流就可以降低
但是还可以看到部分的漏电流可能是因为孔洞所造成的
也就是中间这个图
而采用累晶延伸的4nm及氧化铝
成合成在成长氧化哈
则漏电流可以降低好几个数量级
甚至没有观察到漏电流
而且所形成的堆叠结构
具有致密均匀的界电特性
也就是右边这个图
代表这一次的实验所使用的方法
可以成功的降低漏电流
那么有了基础的材料之后
接下来我们看如何基于化学气象成绩
成长单层二流化木的双杂级长效电晶体
也就是制作出可以工作的元件
为了研究它的电信
使用化学气象层机来成长
单晶单层的二流化木
制作双杂级场效电晶体
包括顶部和底部的结构
顶部杂级的堆叠结构
是采用氧化铝氧化哈薄三层的结构
底部杂级的堆叠结构
是使用100奈米的氮化系
和P型系的基板
而且顶部杂级堆叠的结构
是在单层的二硫化木上
成长厚度0.42奈米的
累晶衍生氧化铝薄膜
再用原子层层积
在250度成长氧化哈薄膜
以及一层薄的接触金属
所以这个实验的顶部杂集堆叠结构
是在细晶圆表面
制作单层的二硫化木二维材料
在成长累晶衍生的氧化铝
作为中介层
在成长氧化哈界电层
最后成长薄金属当作接触电极
形成杂极的结构
同时左边的圆极和右边的极极使用金作为接触金属
而底部杂极的堆叠结构是成长氮化细
在P形的细晶元上
右边这个图是光学显微镜的放大图
我们将其中一个电晶体放大之后
可以看到浅灰色的部分是单层二流化木二维结构
中间是杂极的结构
左边是原极
右边是极极
它的制作是单层的单晶二流化木
使用化学气象成绩
成长在蓝宝石基板上
前驱物包括硫粉末
纯度大于99.5%
与氧化木粉末纯度大于99.5%
成长完成之后
再利用聚甲基丙细酸甲子
PMMA也就是压克力
补助的方式转移搭配热释放胶带
把单层的二流化木转移到100nm厚的氮化细
P型细的基板上面
所以这个元件的制作是先在细晶圆表面
成长100nm厚度的氮化细
中间这一层二流化细二维材料
是先在蓝宝石基板上成长好之后
再利用聚甲基丙烯酸甲子
也就是压克力辅助的方式转移到氮化细的表面
最后在上面制作顶部杂集堆叠的结构
而在二流化木薄膜的上方
利用超高真空电子素真度
在室温下成长单晶的铝层合成
接下来在低压下
使用氧气和氮气混合的气体
进行30分钟的温和氧化
这样就可以在二流化木上
形成不含孔洞
而且均匀的氧化铝层合成
也就是让单晶的铝和氧反应
形成氧化铝
最后再使用原子层层基
以前区物四乙基甲基氨基哈
和氧化剂水
经由化学反应成长氧化哈
接下来我们和大家介绍
短通道顶部杂基长效电晶体
和高阶电长速杂基堆叠结构的性能比较
为了展示氧化哈氧化铝
这个界电层堆叠结构
在短通道顶部杂基整合方面的能力
科学家制作了杂基长度LG大约100奈米
等效氧化成厚度EOT大约1nm的顶部杂极长效电晶体
使用晶作为接触电极并且量测通到区域附近的截面穿透式电子显微镜影像观察它的结构以及能量散射X光光谱
元素映射图
来量测它的元素成分
所以这个元件的结构
是在P型的细晶元上
成长厚度100奈米的氮化系
并且事先将二流化木的二维材料
制作在蓝宝石晶元上
再转移到氮化系表面
并且在上面成长累金铝
再利用氧气和氮气氧化
形成累金衍生氧化铝界面层
并且在上面成长氧化哈界电层
再成长氮化钛和薄金属作为杂极的接触电极
而圆极和极极使用金作为接触电极
左边这个图是截面电子显微镜照片
左边是圆极
右边是极极
上面是杂极
LG是通道长度
LSD是原集到极极的长度
浅灰色这一层是累金衍生氧化铝界面层
科学家取出左半边这个区域
量测能量散射X光光谱
得到右边这个结果
粉红色的部分是硫
也就是下面这一层薄薄的二流化木二维材料
黄色的是金
也就是左边这个原集
浅蓝色这一层是累金衍生氧化铝界面层
红色这一层是氧化哈界电层
蓝色是氮化钛
绿色是钵接触金属
从前面的介绍
可以发现在金属接触区域的附近
厚度2.9奈米的原子层层机氧化哈界电层
分布均匀
而且层机在金属接触电极和二流化木的通道上面
而中间具有0.42奈米厚度的氧化铝界电层
这个结果显示通道的长度
仍然可以进一步缩小到10奈米以下的可能性
意思是这个通道长度还可以再缩短
典型元件的转移特性和输出特性
包括在原级积极电压VDS1V的时候
可以实现高跨导每微米0.45毫西门值
在原级积极电压VDS2V的时候
顶部杂极电压VTG1.5V
这个时候导通电流可以达到每微米0.45毫安培
所以左边这个图显示
当积极原级电压VDS1伏特的时候
跨导GM可以达到每微米0.45毫西门子
而右边这个图显示
积极原级电压VDS2伏特的时候
顶部杂级电压1.5伏特
则导通电流可以达到每微米450毫安培
相当于每微米0.45毫安培
最后这个研究的结论是
累经衍生氧化铝界面层
主要的作用就是改善二维材料的界面
科学家发现
累经衍生氧化铝的界面层
可以提供高品质
而且结构均匀的界面
来改善后续在上面成长氧化哈
沉积过程中的成和均匀性
也就是让氧化哈的表面更均匀
这样就可以降低界面
排列不整齐的原子表面粗糙度降低
而且缺陷密度也降低
这样就可以提高界电材料
氧化哈的均匀性
并且降低界电材料的界面相关散射效应
这样就可以增加宅子迁移率
也就是增加电子电动移动的速度
其次在二流化木二维材料
和氧化哈界电材料中间
增加这一层累晶衍生氧化铝
层合成
可以使二流化木的二维电子通道
和氧化哈高界电常数的界电材料之间
直接的作用解鱼
也就是不会互相影响
大家都知道在高度缩小的元件当中
通道使用的二流化木二维材料
和高界电常数的氧化哈之间
直接的作用会造成通道的宅子迁移率变差
所以如果让这两层解鱼
也就是变得无关
那么就可以增加宅子的迁移率
换句话说
氧化铝可以作为界面缓冲层
来改善上面的氧化哈界电层
和下面的二流化木二维材料之间的特性
这样就可以抑制氧化哈界电层
引起的散射效应
包括远端生子散射和其他界面散射
达到改善宅子迁移率
也就是让电子电动移动的速度更快
经由前面的介绍
大家会发现这一次台积电
和阳明交通大学共同发表的论文
就是在二流化木二维材料
和氧化哈界电材料之间
成长一层累晶衍生的氧化铝界面层
这一层累晶衍生的氧化铝界面层
主要的作用就是改善二维材料
二流化木的界面特性
这样就可以减少散色效应
增加宅子在二流化木
二维材料里面的迁移率
也就是增加电子电动移动的速度
而且在论文里面
台积电已经把这样的技术做成元件
虽然电子通道100奈米有点大
但是未来可以缩小到10奈米以下
将成为下一代先进制程重要的元件结构
好我们今天的节目到这边
大家对于先进制程使用二流化木这种二维材料
以及累经衍生氧化铝界面层有相关的问题
欢迎大家发表在影片的下方
我们再来讨论
谢谢大家
晚安
拜拜
字幕志愿者 杨茜茜